the Joe Rogan experience it's one of the
more fascinating things about people
though that we have the ability to
contemplate the possibilities that we
have the ability to look at this and go
okay what are we doing here
hold on right hold on we're making a
mistake here look what wheats got us
doing look at Rice's got us doing damn
it look how much people there are in the
city there's so many people in the city
what are we gonna feed all these people
[ __ ] right we didn't think of this we
just kept breeding and you know that's
the big concern when people start
developing too into new areas when
people start expanding the the
technological or the the rather societal
sprawl when you see these urban sprawl
is just slowly encroaching on new land
right and pushing out into areas where
there was no houses before that's always
weird for me when I Drive by a place
like Boulder Colorado does a really good
job of limiting the amount of
construction that gets done there right
they're pretty fierce about it but even
they have been sort of lightening up a
little things have been getting built
and every now and then I'll drive by
like if I'm in Colorado my oh that
wasn't there before
now it's there everybody thinks it's
harmless no big deal just a new building
used to be an open field who's that
helping it's not helping anyone
and then another building outside of
that and then you know if you could you
had the ability to look in time 50 years
from now you yeah you see this spread
where this weird wart of humanity and it
starts moving across the globe this
co-feature and Google Maps where you can
have for Google Earth where you can have
time lapses from satellite photos like
past six years and for love you look at
Dubai like 30 years ago nothing and yes
I devised a crazy example that's a crazy
example that place is so strange
it's like Las Vegas some steroids yeah
Las Vegas on steroids with its own
Islands man-made islands the shape of
the world like all the different
continents the world you seen that yeah
and it's not doing it like it's some of
it apparently they have to like keep
adjusting because the tide rises and the
pretty dumb actually is this the Google
Maps thing called another one but
there's another way to do by oh my god
this is insane
this is insane it's happening so fast
how many years is this spanning Oh 20 oh
my god that's amazing so the actually
some of our engineers used to work for
the dredger and they helped build the
the palm islands and pretty the problem
is that the water doesn't really move in
the arms of the the palms so it kind of
gets stinky and oh okay so this prime
real estate
that's just stinks oh no really oh that
makes sense but the water in between it
would get stale of course that makes
sense
[ __ ] this is bonkers this videos bunker
you know these are actual oh there's the
yeah that's the thing so all that water
inside yeah it doesn't get recycled it
doesn't move around yeah how the [ __ ]
that they had to do that to keep the
like an ocean break right suppose the
water from smashing into it like the
outside rim you can't just pump
everything so now what do they do with
all the stinky water you just accept it
good question that [ __ ] world's
tallest building is BA Nana's right that
thing I've seen pictures that people
have taken from the top floor it doesn't
even look real like all you flat
earthers you need to go to Dubai get up
there you could literally see the curve
yeah and when you stand on its foot they
because of its shape it looks they even
told her can you see the curve from up
there see if go to think so no thing so
maybe on an airplane you can't you can
kind that's true what a bit of yeah yeah
yeah yeah
you gotta be way up right would you go
and one of those virgins trips they do a
virgin spaceship fly above the earth and
once there's good safety statistics
right for you
[ __ ] early adopting yeah it's pretty not
good to be an early adopter either yeah
well just base area
what kind of psychos and want to be on
that first flight well I suppose
Richards would have to go and one of the
first ones themselves right oh if I was
him I would clone myself and put a fake
me on that and see if that [ __ ] blows
off I wouldn't trust Sun Devil
what is this Jamie is this for oh I'm
not gonna deck at saying this I'm
getting vertigo just looking down I am
freaking out
I get like legit this is all GoPro so
this is what would flat earthers you
just show that the earth is actually
flat it's the perspective shift but just
the height of that goddamn thing makes
my palms sweat I was there last year and
there was somebody sticking her phone
out of the No yes oh god damn people are
crazy yes
how did she dropped it and it fell and
just went right through someone's
[ __ ] head like literally like a
missile in your head would just explode
you manage getting hit in the head with
a cellphone from a mile up [ __ ]
that's good [ __ ] people are so
crazy down we take so long to but the
word burst mode there's a new
perspective to that term they should
have like an alarm that goes off when
someone dropped something someone can
quickly hit an alarm and by the time it
hits the bottom the bottom floor will
hear bad man they get all back away from
the building these guys are on the tip
top no shut the [ __ ] up oh my god
they're hanging on like these guys this
kids with his dad it looks gross dad's
crazy too right you're both [ __ ] nuts
dude my hands are sweating right now I
can't handle these oh that dude that
we've had on James Kerr with a K do
Kingman Kingman James the guy who does
those said it Kingman right he does
these videos from these [ __ ] places
Kingston thank you sorry James it's
America I smoked a lot weed no he's uh
he lives in England okay
and he takes these videos where he's
like hanging on by one hand with a
[ __ ] selfie stick yes looking down
cyant skyscrapers and ants sweat so hard
just watching those I can't imagine if I
was actually doing that
a terrible [ __ ] instinct or a
terrible thing that happens to people
when you see people hanging onto
something your hands sweat so do your
hands sweat when you're hanging is not
helping you that's the worst thing that
can happen is your hands get all
slippery
[Applause]